depuis bientôt deux semaines donc
l'ukraine est bombardée par l'aviation
russe résultat vous allez le voir de
très nombreux bâtiments ont été réduits
à néant images de kharkiv deuxième ville
du pays qu'on va peut-être apercevoir
inscrite aussi comme ville créative et
où les destructions s'accumulent on
s'inquiète là-bas pour le patrimoine
ukrainien certains bâti certaines
oeuvres qui seront irremplaçable demain
on en parle avec notre invité ses vous
lazare hendou assomo bonjour vous êtes
directeur du centre du patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco merci de nous
accorder quelques instants à mot
peut-être tout d'abord de votre
sentiment en ukraine il ya au total sept
sites inscrits au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco la cathédrale sainte-sophie du
11e siècle il ya aussi des sites comme
le centre commémoratif de l'holocauste
babia ou encore le musée les trésors
historiques de l'ukraine à quel point
êtes-vous inquiet aujourd'hui
écoutés l'unesco est très préoccupée
avec toutes ces nouvelles de
bombardements qui continue lui qui s'est
intensifié dans dans quasiment du tout
évident que vous avez montré dans vos
reportages donc vous savez que ces
bombardements et directement son
provoque des situations humanitaires non
seulement mais on essaye de nous au
niveau d'une escouade d'évaluer les
dégâts dans tout le domaine de
compétence notamment pour la culture et
vous l'avez dit c'est un pays riche en
histoire avec un riche patrimoine de 7
des sites importants qui sont sur la
patrimoine mondial mais aussi une vie
culturelle très riche avec des villes
qui sont des vignes du réseau des villes
créatives de l'unesco des musées qui
ferment des églises des lieux région
également qu'ils sont qui sont
certainement viser toute cette situation
est aujourd'hui très préoccupante on a
des exemples 1 déjà très concrets de
destructions notamment au nord de kiev
on a tous aperçu ces images du musée des
ventes yves et de sa collection d'art
naïf partis en fumée avec eux
semble-t-il vous nous en direz peut-être
plus 25 tableaux de la peintre
ukrainienne maria prima tchenko qui
l'abrité est ce que vous arrivez déjà à
recenser ces destructions et ses oeuvres
qu'il faut mettre à l'abri aujourd'hui
écoutés nous avons commencé ce travail
immédiatement et nous sommes en contact
avec des professionnels sur le terrain
nous sommes en contact avec les
autorités craignent d'ailleurs c'est
vraiment l'occasion de rendre hommage à
tous ces professionnels qui continuent
de se mobiliser pour sauver leur
patrimoine dans ces villes qui sont qui
sont touchés vous savez la journée qui
est une ville inscrite sur la liste
indicative décide qui aurait pu être qui
pourrait être inscrit au patrimoine
mondial dans les années à venir il y à
des bombardements dans un centre
historique et aux musiques faire mes
collections sont en danger on voit déjà
les premiers danger et nous l'avons
signalé dans dans nos nos déclarations
la dernière déclaration de l'unesco sur
la sur cette situation des peintures
nous allons nous allons continuer nous
travaillons avec nos différents
partenaires pour refaire un
monitoring de la situation avec des
images satellitaires régulièrement et
nous allons nous continuons à travailler
là dessus nous sommes au pied ni the
alerted alerté c'est une chose
évidemment mettre des moyens en oeuvre
on est une autre et ça devient forcément
plus concret on a vu des images assez
assez troublante ces derniers jours
d'ukrainiens de civils ukrainien emballé
notamment eux mêmes avec parfois de
simples couvertures des statuts des
édifices pour les protéger des
déflagrations moyens somme toute assez
dérisoires que prévoyez-vous gative
quelque chose de prévu concrètement pour
aider les ukrainiens à préserver ce
patrimoine oui oui alors dans les jours
à venir nous allons réunir des
professionnels ceux avec lesquels nous
arrivons à être en contact pour bien
prendre en compte tous leurs besoins
immédiats rien qui censure sur le
terrain exemple très simple en cas de
feu il faut des extincteurs par exemple
pour pour éteindre le feu nous avons
mobilisé une équipe d'experts qui vivent
tous les jours prête à apporter tous les
conseils techniques
les recommandations nous sommes en
contact avec ces associations qui se
mobilisent sur le terrain de la société
civile que ce soit elles vivent en
particulier où nous avons j'ai encore
été en contact avec le président de
cette association minière pour essayer
de comprendre tout cela nous devons
accompagner ces professionnels c'est
cette société civile qui se mobilisent
pour sauver le patrimoine parce que avec
ses acteurs ce sera aussi le moyen de
contribuer dès demain pour relèvement de
ce peuple de cette société qui
aujourd'hui est traumatisée par cette
situation c'est toute une histoire
commune aussi parfois avec avec la
russie un que que l'ukraine partage d'où
cette position de certains experts qui
estiment que compte tenu de cette
histoire commune vladimir poutine sera
peut-être moins brutale dont son
offensive sur sur kiev la capitale qui
abrite notamment des églises orthodoxes
vous partagez cet avis vaut aussi
nous espérons que kiev ne sera pas
bombarder parce que c'est une scène cet
ensemble de cette ville du patrimoine
mondial où se trouve également la
cathédrale sainte-sophie mais aussi un
ensemble monastique la fin de la vague
qui sont qui sont importants pas
simplement ou qui sont importants pour
pour la vie religieuse de l'ukraine et
de la russie nous espérons vraiment que
ces deux villes que ce site sera épargné
mais je peux vous dire que nous sommes
très inquiets nous voilà inquiétudes ont
leur entendu sur cette antenne merci à
vous lazare elle ou nous